deep frying a turkey can
oftentimes be incredibly dangerous
so why don't we try a different cooking
method
let's send our turkey up into space
and have it come to earth while moving
at the speed of light
do you think this would be any safer
how fast is the speed of light
could a turkey moving this fast
damage the earth and
what would happen once it reaches our
atmosphere
[Music]
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if a turkey hit the earth at the speed
of light
the speed of light is nearly 300 000
kilometers per second if an
object were going this fast it could
circle the earth
seven and a half times in just a single
second
so what would happen if we made a turkey
move this fast
and then hurled it toward our planet
we go any further we should let you know
that it's impossible for an object
to move at the speed of light that's
because
the faster an object moves the more
its mass increases and its length
contracts
in other words when our turkey is moving
at the speed of light
it would have an infinite mass and a
length
of zero which is impossible
but we won't let our fun stop there
instead
we're going to have our turkey move at
99.99
the speed of light suck on that einstein
and now moving at this speed in space
the turkey is coming for earth
but before it even hits our planet we'd
notice
some of the effects long before it
impacts
as the turkey is moving through earth's
atmosphere
it would start to slam into atmospheric
particles
since it's moving at such a high speed
the turkey would
begin to get ripped apart if you wanted
to look up in the sky
you'd see bright explosions in our
atmosphere
but the volume of the explosions would
probably make you
instinctively run for cover and hide
this might not sound all that terrible
but it would still cause
massive destruction on earth's surface
the closest modern equivalent to
something like this
would be the chelyabinsk meteor in 2013.
that meteor exploded at a height of 23.3
kilometers
and when that happened it resulted in 1
000 people getting injured
and huge amounts of property damage
our turkey moving at the speed of light
would be equal to
40 000 of those meteors hitting earth
and these explosions wouldn't happen all
at once but
sporadically as it moves through the
atmosphere
as they happened their shock waves would
cause buildings and
windows to be completely destroyed
and if this were to happen it would be
the earth's
best case scenario that's because
this turkey hasn't even hit the planet
yet
but if it did come right for us then
the results would be even worse
due to all the energy behind it if the
turkey
hit new york city at 99.99
of the speed of light it would be like
dropping 400
nuclear bombs this would completely
destroy the city
not to mention parts of the planet
itself
the impact from this massive explosion
could destroy the earth's crust causing
magma to spew up and fill the streets
massive fires would start and millions
of people would die
but ground zero wouldn't be the only
place
heavily affected an impact to earth like
this
could cause earthquakes and fires all
across north america
an entire half of the world would be
completely destroyed
just from a harmless turkey
so the speed of light can be pretty
dangerous
but what might happen if you rode your
bike at this speed
well we'll leave that story for another
what if oh yeah and
happy thanksgiving